[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition de votre journal local
voici les titres de ce mercredi 4
janvier 2017
cent cinq ans et un nouveau record de
vitesse sur piste robert marchand vient
de parcourir en l'espace d'une heure peu
d'une vingtaine de kilomètres sur la
piste du vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines
notre journaliste sur place miquel et
demi d'euros nous en dira plus dans
cette tentative dans notre édition en
politique marie christine le tarn avec
la nouvelle maire socialiste de
guyancourt présenté hier soir ses
premiers voeux en qualité à des deals
l'occasion pour elle de faire un point
sur les projets de la commune vous
l'entendrez enfin nous vous dévoilerons
les temps forts culturels pour 2017
théâtre danse concerts sont au programme
des salles saint-quentinoise c'est un
exploit un nouveau record pour robert
marchand à 105 ans le sportif qui a
connu les deux guerres mondiales qui a
été un bûcheron au canada ou encore
vendeur de poulets en amérique du sud
vient de parcourir un peu moins de 23 km
en l'espace d'une heure sur la piste du
vélodrome de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
vous envoyer quelques images à l'écran
un véritable exploit il verrait
performance que qu'a pu suivre notre
journaliste sportif miquel et demi
d'euros et nous racontera les coulisses
de cet exploit
enfin deux journal ce n'est pas un
record mais une première politique pour
marie-christine le tarnec la nouvelle
maire socialiste de guyancourt présenté
hier soir ses voeux en tant que maire de
la ville après avoir succédé en décembre
dernier à françois de ligne et à la
danse dans un premier temps aux salué le
travail de son prédécesseur
depuis le pavillon waldeck-rousseau ce
mardi soir elle a aussi dressé sa
feuille de route pour l'année qui arrive
entre l'ouverture de nouveaux
équipements de santé avec notamment une
clinique de soins au pont du rotois ray
la présentation de et la préservation
plutôt de l'environnement avec un projet
mêlant l'agriculture de proximité
insertion à la minière lors de son
intervention
elle s'est aussi adressé à l'exécutif de
saint quentin en yvelines depuis
il ya un an des tensions persistent dans
la définition des compétences de la
nouvelle agglomération élargie
on les écoute à ce propos au micro de
wilfrid richier et patrick jacques de
dixmude
on a effectivement rejeté dans son des
compétences puisque on pense qu'ils
encore du temps et qu'on peut encore
avoir des discussions entre son
puisqu'on n'est pas tous d'accord sur
les mêmes sujets et il faut se laisser
du temps puisque c'est l'avenir de
l'agglo qui se joue là
mais pour nous il est important de
prendre du temps de laisser du temps ou
continuer à discuter à 12
on veut absolument se faire respecter et
on veut avoir notre place aussi au sein
de la communauté d'agglomération ont
fait partie des douze communes ma
commune comme les autres les autres
communes de gauche et il a absolument
pas question de ne pas se faire
respecter de pas avoir les mêmes droits
que les autres communes qui sont rentrés
et l'intégralité de cet entretien est à
retrouver dans notre émission 7 8 et les
invités de ce mercredi en politique
toujours sylvia pinel la présidente du
prg est candidate à la primaire de la
gauche était en déplacement hier aux
mureaux l'ancienne miss du logement a
évoqué notamment le droit des femmes
lors d'une table ronde
les précisions d'haussmann vendeurs d
sur des images divines première mardi 3
janvier sylvia pinel président du parti
radical de gauche s'est rendu aux
mureaux le but de la journée rencontrer
les associations de la ville et écouter
leurs demandes
je suis une élue locale une élue de
terrain et je crois que il y a sur les
territoires dans les communes beaucoup
de bonne initiative qui mérite d'être
regardée de près pour que l'on puisse
ensuite les dupliquer j'ai fonctionné
ainsi lorsque justement j'étais au
gouvernement pour améliorer un certain
nombre de dispositifs pour aménager
notre territoire
l'un des thèmes évoqués lors de cette
table ronde avec l'ancienne ministre du
logement
c'est le droit des femmes un sujet qui
tient à coeur à la candidate et qu'elle
souhaite mettre en avant lors de la
primaire de la gauche
l'égalité hommes-femmes en reste encore
un sujet majeur dans notre pays puisque
même si pendant le quinquennat de
françois hollande un certain nombre de
choses ont progressé nous restons
aujourd'hui dans des situations qui sont
sur le plan salarial inacceptable sur le
plan de l'accès aux soins
intolérable aujourd'hui un certain
nombre de réactionnaire conserver
remettre en cause le droit des femmes à
disposer de leur corps à travers lire et
j'ai donc nous entendons est une vigie
républicaine en entendant des lanceurs
alerte sur le sujet d'égalité hommes
femmes la présidente du parti radical de
gauche continue son tour de france pour
séduire son électorat
le premier tour de la primaire se
déroule le 22 janvier prochain en
culture à présent le début de l'année
2010 est marquée évidemment la reprise
des saisons la vingtaine de salles
saint-quentinoise s'apprête à rouvrir
leurs portes pour certaines c'est même
déjà le cas on fait un tour d'horizon
avec vous mélanie poquet pour ça à
nicolas lorsque tu as fait la saison a
repris aujourd'hui pour au moins deux
salles la ferme de bel ébat qu'une pièce
de théâtre le pays où l'on n'arrive
jamais de godefroy ségal et le théâtre
national de saint quentin en yvelines
qui propose une reprise culturel
dansante à voir en famille ces suites
curieuse de la compagnie québécois
québécoise cas public j'en propose
nicolas qu'on reste sur cette salle et
sur deux spectacles bien de saison alors
le premier c'est du cirque tour de la
classe on voit des images jamais na est
une jongleuse de la compagnie non nova
elle présente ppp un travail sur
l'identité sont les aléas de la vie
représentée par de la glace et pour le
second spectacle là je laisse lionel
masse et à le directeur du théâtre nous
le présenter nathalie de ces on la
connaît bien entendu comme comme
chanteuse comme cantatrice mais on la
connaît moins comme comédienne et le
interprète à la façon de beckett une
femme qui attend qu'attend-elle alors il
ya tout le temps tout un travail sonore
en hors champ on se rend compte
finalement
et de façon tragique que cette femme est
finalement à sailly
certainement au moment de l'occupation
française par des agents de la gestapo
et alors que l'on pense qu'elle attend
son amant en fait elle a tant sonneurs
dernière en retard
[Musique]
il est en retard au
vient prendre les juifs
alors mélanie vous nous avez parlé de
théâtre de cirque mais il y en a pour
tous les autres goûts aussi pour tous
les autres logos on vous pourrez aussi
bien voir de la danse notamment ifrad ya
eliane gallois aux prises à elancourt
ses représentations du 21 mars
s'inscrive dans le cadre du festival
féminin pluriel en musique pourquoi pas
vous rendre à la batterie de guyancourt
vous pourrez écouter irani mène un
groupe suisse eux ils viennent en mars
les ventes passent et pablo moses
février la merise de trappes
elle est l'accueil était là aussi en
février et si jamais c'est de l'humour
qui vous intéressent pourquoi pas
direction montigny le bretonneux
olivier de benoist sera sur la scène de
la salle jacques brel en mars et séance
de rattrapage vous pourrez aussi le voir
aux clayes-sous-bois en avril on
continue tour des salles aussi nul oscar
n'avait de la verrière c'est un voyage à
travers le monde qui a proposé musique
celtique pour la saint-patrick et
l'orchestré national de barbès qui lui
sera présent en février mais surtout une
belle page musique afro-américaine des
rencontres dans la ville et un concert
le 28 janvier avec le saint quentin
gospel et cette fois on écoute camilla
belle baie la directrice de la salle
c'est un projet qui est né dans nos
têtes d'une envie de de partir de
changer un petit peu de la chanson
française
même si on aime beaucoup ça et de partir
un peu à la découverte d'un autre
continent
et puis c'est aussi un moyen d'aborder
plein d'autres questions puisque
l'histoire de cette musique elle est
vraiment lié à l'évolution de la société
américaine
à la question des droits civiques de
l'égalité des droits pour tous et ça
c'était vraiment un sujet qui nous
tenait à coeur
[Musique]
ap
merci beaucoup mélanie pour toutes ces
précisions et c'est difficile on le sait
en deux minutes de présenter la
programmation de toutes les salles
saint-quentinoise pour les plus curieux
il y a le site internet kiosque
www.kia.ca caille point fr direction
aussi pourquoi pas les sites internet
des salles pour découvrir tout ce qui
vous attend pour le reste de la saison
culturelle le début de l'année marque
aussi le début des bonnes résolutions
parmi les plus connus il ya évidemment
la reprise du sport surtout après les
fêtes c'est ce que nous sommes allés
vérifier dans une salle de montigny le
bretonneux reportage de camille lambert
et mathilde demi le sport l'une des
résolutions phare des français pour 2017
selon un sondage réalisé par ipsos
l'activité sportive représentent 30% des
bonnes résolutions de cette année une
fête que ça le début de l'année ya
beaucoup de gens qui me donne de bonnes
résolutions il ya beaucoup sont dans sa
voix ses bonnes résolutions à prendre ça
fait du bien et que même ça change je me
suis inscris naya il ya un mois à la
salle donc c'est tout nouveau et donc
voilà
bah oui pourquoi pas enfin décider un
petit peu avant la mi mai pour cette
année me motive tapis de course biking
ou fitness les débutants peuvent évoluer
sur des machines simples d'utilisation
pour se remettre en jambes en douceur et
le mieux après les fêtes c'est le cardio
et la musculation en général qui revient
souvent c'est les personnes qui veulent
perdre de la masse grasse ça est plutôt
orienté cardio avec toute une partie
renforcement musculaire derrière et
après c'est les personnes en général
c'est de la prise de masse prise de
volume donc la presse est vraiment accès
plus tôt sur la musculation que sur la
partie cardio c'est d'être régulier ça
je pense que c'est l'importance qu'ils
aient beaucoup de personnes qui vont
sûrement s'inscrit en janvier on va les
voir pendant un mois et puis un mois
puis on les reverra au mois de juin quoi
on se préparait pour la plage roi
ouverte depuis décembre cette nouvelle
enseigne de montigny le bretonneux a
déjà boosté ses abonnements
elle espère entre 200 à 700 nouveaux
adhérents pour le mois de janvier et
reste à tenir ses bonnes résolutions au
moins jusqu'à l'an prochain et du sport
lui il vient d'en faire cet après midi
on revient comme promis sur l'expo de
robert marchand qui a parcouru un peu
plus de 22 km heure 22 kilomètres donc
22 km en 1h à l'âge de 105 ans ça s'est
passé cet après midi au vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines et notre
journaliste michael et demi d'euros a
suivi en direct cette performance il
était en direct au vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines il nous donne
quelques précisions sur les coulisses de
cet exploit on écoute alors robert
version vient tout juste de se rendre au
contrôle antidopage et il a terminé il
ya tout juste une heure sa course c'est
donc un formidable exploit qu'a réalisé
sous nos yeux au vélodrome saint quentin
en yvelines à cet homme robert marchand
je vous rappelle 105 ans l'homme qui a
connu les deux guerres mondiales et 16
président de la république il a réussi à
battre le record de l'heure il a réalisé
24 5 km avec une vitesse moyenne de 22
km heure alors pour nous parler de cet
exploit
jean michel richefort quitter dans le
team du coup de robert marchand alors
jean-michel cet exploit vous surprend-il
oui c'est exceptionnel bien sûr je suis
surpris je suis je suis ému il n'y a pas
de mots parce que mon coeur a battu très
fort pendant pendant sept heures on l'a
entraîné ces derniers jours on était sur
des bases de 40 secondes
autour et là il a toujours été en
dessous du tableau de marche le plus
optimiste il faisait des tours à 38
secondes à 37 secondes ce qui a été
absolument
prodigieux et je craignais une grande
dans les dix dernières minutes mais il a
une telle volonté d'y arriver qu'il est
allé au bout de sonneurs de sans
problème il est descendu de vélo c'est
la joie de vivre
voilà il a parfaitement récupéré après
trois minutes après trois minutes son
coeur était redescendu à 80 pulsations
minute à ses provisions
il a même terminé plus fort qui n'avait
commencé oui bien sûr il a accéléré
accéléré et dans le dernier quart
d'heure après il est redescendu mamie
notre électorat 36 secondes
j'avais un peu peur je craignais
justement que ça il trop vite mais non
je pense qu'il était bien il était bien
et à tous les tours il faisait un petit
signe de tête
ça voulait dire qu'il était parfait il a
peut-être été également poussé à 1 par
le public oui il était poussé par le
public et puis il a toujours la volonté
de bien faire et avec robert il faut
calmer le jeu quoi c'est vraiment la
marque d'un champion de vouloir se
surpasser surtout faire plaisir parce
que il est bien il est avec ses copains
il est avec ses amis le vélo pour pour
lui c'est du plaisir chaque jour il fait
du vélo il s'entretient il fait de la
gym
donc c'est son moteur en quelque sorte
est aujourd'hui bon avec ses copains de
l'ardéchois ses copains de mitry mory
qui sont venus l'encourager
donc voilà que du plaisir pour lui je
pense et ce n'est peut-être pas terminé
dans deux ans robert marchand pourrait
battre un nouveau record
merci michael pour toutes ces précisions
nous vous proposerons d'ailleurs un
reportage complet sur cet exploit dans
notre édition de demain
fin du journal rendez vous donc demain
jeudi aux horaires habituels pour une
nouvelle édition locale nos reportages
eux sont à revoir dès ce soir henri pelé
sur notre site internet ou sur
l'application mobile tv fil 78
bonne soirée à tous
[Musique]